um
so anyhow let's try the uh center
counter or
scandinavian
i don't play this
maybe because it's uh
a gambit but i'm gonna i'm gonna try it
could i actually do this
we're gonna see so opting for some rapid
development let's see how white
approaches this will that pond be taken
what i'll look to do
with uh being down upon here
is
maintain control of the d4 square
and uh i might want to be placing this
knight in an in an uncomfortable pin
let's see though
first things first let's give some
support to this pawn
and what else
what else is the
scoop here
okay just uh more development in
let's go more development
and there may be one day the possibility
for
tricks on this square
we're gonna see right now this looks
like my bishop is just doing a whole lot
of staring at his own pawn
but one day he might be staring at h2
and
sacrificing himself
just to allow for knight g4 queen h4
stuff
let's take
my main focus is to get a lot of
development in
and with this last move i'm threatening
to uh well
i'm giving up yet another pawn
let's see what white does about it okay
they're going right after that pawn
and
bishop here is maybe something i want to
do just to stop castling
interesting that might actually be
pretty good
let me see
bishop here
or rook here
this bishop is unprotected if rook here
in the there's castle there's a check
maybe knight check or queen check on c7
bishop here bishop takes rope queen
takes for a queen takes bishop queen
takes pawn i think i win this rook with
insurance
with check and the king is running for
the hills
or is he
i don't know i'd end up losing my light
square bishop boom boom boom boom boom
boom with check i don't know i can't
excuse me i can't run all the
calculations right now i don't think but
it's
certainly a very lively position i'm
looking at forcing moves if i'm to be a
bit more general about the moves i'm
considering right now
it's the bishop check or a queen check
i don't know how inconvenient would be
that i think the bishop just plays here
there's no issue maybe
after all this
um maybe it's best i just play rook here
bishop here bishop takes queen takes
queen takes bishop
queen takes pawn there's no way to save
the rook because i'm controlling f1
queen takes bishop what would i have i
could throw in a rook check or something
but there's always a bishop block isn't
there
i don't know i'm gonna i'm a scaredy cat
this is the scaredy cat line
rook v8
rook b8 don't just just be a lazy
calculator just play rook b8 don't give
up material so quickly
so now this is juicy
chop check queen out
but there's a defense chop boom check
king runs away queen h4 bishop f4 is
available defending h2 and
hitting my rook
so what does this all mean
well it means i'm still going to do this
move
and as a follow-up i'm not going to play
my knight here
or yes i am
make up your mind would you
okay i still am going to do this
but not with the typical continuation
queen here
but rather queen c7
or am i
because wait if king takes and i give
check if the king gets a little bit
crazy and plays to this square
if i play queen c7
then there's a bishop f4
counter-attacking
sneakiness
how about i give it an immediate check i
think an immediate check
first
can i always be assured i'm getting this
guy back i am down just upon now king
side is compromised i have pressure on
this b pawn and
also i can look at it as
there being always the possibility for
let's say opposite color bishop ending
where
being down upon might not be so bad so
that
might might not be so bad so there's
possibilities
for uh holding a draw in other words
i wouldn't have to be
too too much concerned about being down
upon if we're into that type of
situation now if there's this kind of
block going on i think this is a problem
because this weakens the light squares
and what piece does my opponent not have
the light square bishop
so i wonder if i should first throw in a
check
i'm assuming the king of play here going
here is probably crazy because i
recapture with check
where the forcing moves queen queen
takes here with uh just the
thought of playing my bishop here
that's exactly what i'm going to do
down upon but
it's
pretty irrelevant
i think
it's quite awkward to get developed as
well on this queen side as soon as this
guy moves
the rook just takes the heart out of the
queenside position
i think that's a good description you
could be giving to this center pawn
right here
i heard that i'm not sure what gm it was
use that
to describe
a group of pawns here but of these abc
pawns this b-pawn acts as the heart
you take this guy out and the other ones
become weak as a result both would be
isolated
squares on the same file
of isolated pawns act as potential
outposts for pieces good homes for
pieces
so
right here's a mate threat
i could give a check first but um
i like this making one threat
if the rook plays here i have a night
check followed by a night here and the
whole family's hit
that's exactly what's happening so i'm
just wondering if there's a mate i'm
seeing just here here and i get the
queen
after check the king has to play here
is there anything better i'm not seeing
it
so this is check king here is forced
knight takes f
and uh i was thinking for a brief second
about playing my queen here but that is
covered
so i'm just gonna go with this
so the queen is out and
okay
good game let's uh back up that got
really wild really quick
it was a short game but it's
i mean that that could easily happen
just because of how opened
a position it became so this was
not sure what you call this this is uh
some some gambit line it wasn't popping
up on chess cube as anything but again
the main idea and this is the case with
most gambits it's just to facilitate
your development get in uh try and show
that the compensation you have for
being down upon
is having
more of your pieces out
uh or being able to get more of your
pieces out more quickly in the early
stages
i'm not so sure about the pawn push
maybe this is
where there's an adjustment even though
it seems as though you're winning
another pawn
i have so much development in and this
night
one way to view it is that that night
is being your night on f3 is being
exchanged after my queen night and this
guy right here is probably the number
one defender of your own kingside so
even though you net another pawn
you end up losing that pawn back you're
still up upon but
again development and issues on h2 the
unprotected nature of the bishop
is maybe something that would um
um you know have um you know you'd have
maybe some second thoughts about the the
d4 move now knowing that well my your
knight is kind of drifting away from
uh the defense of your own king side
it's it's kind of naked right here
except for just these pawns
no more minor pieces around to help out
so as an
improvement maybe
maybe you could just be going with d3
here
that's one thing or if you wanted to be
super solid
and anticipating an eventual
let's say annoying bishop move here
pinning the knight
maybe you could run with knight f3
bishop e2
and d3 just kind of saying really really
solid preventing any nonsense with this
pin
that's another approach
knight f3 d3
bishop to e2
so you could you could look into that as
well
um
i think black is uh
actually turning out to be better
after this bishop takes pawn here
this is kind of tough
two bishops
doing good here in the night here
possibilities tough to defend your
king's side and you kind of have to go
castle right away
because of rook here coming up soon
so that's my suggestion you could uh you
could play a little bit more defensively
and just hang on to that pawn right
there and still maybe work
make me work a bit more to show the
compensation that i have